welcome to the smite God revealed for
Osiris broken god of the afterlife
in smite Osiris cuts through his
opponents with his sickle as a warrior
never has there been nor shall there be
a king more perfect than Osiris son of
the earth god GEB Osiris was divine
royalty by birth and all the land his
birthright benevolence and prosperity
were the hallmarks of his reign would
that he had been left to shape the world
but the jealousy of his brother set
changed the course of fate seeking to
usurp the throne set deceived and
murdered his brother tearing his body to
pieces and casting them across the land
Isis Osiris his wife secretly fled while
set plunged the kingdom into darkness
for years she toiled to reassemble her
husband while his spirit form his ba
endured yet for all her searching she
could not find every part of him though
not strong enough to defy set in this
incomplete form Osiris gave Isis a son
that would topple the tyrant set and
restore balance to Egypt what remains of
Osiris is a fragment of what he once was
robbed of his crown over the earth he
now governs the realm of the dead with
the same benevolence he ruled the living
Oh Cyrus's passive is called fragmented
after eight uses of an ability Osiris
transforms into his spirit form he may
walk through all enemies and enemy
blocking abilities and his basic attacks
do not incur a movement penalty this
effect is broken after several
successful basic attacks
additionally Osiris has a four hit basic
attack combo the last two hits dealing
area damage his first ability is called
sickle strike
Osiris throws his sickle dealing damage
and stopping at the first enemy hit the
enemy is also slowed his second ability
is called spirit flail Osiris imbues his
flail with spiritual energy striking at
the target location if an enemy is under
the effect of sickle strike the target
slow is increased in power and duration
Osiris's third ability is called
judgement tether Osiris flings out mummy
wraps tethering himself to all nearby
enemies enemies deal reduced damage
while tethered and at the end of the
duration are stunned Osiris's ultimate
is called Lord of the afterlife Osiris
sheds any remaining fragments gaining
the benefit of his passive and leaps
forward Osiris will target the lowest
health God in the radius and rip a
fragment of their spirit dealing damage
and preventing the target from healing
in this first fight Osiris comes from
the jungle for gank taking down the
nearby enemy minions with hand of the
Gods he quickly takes down he bow with a
sickle strike spirit flail and judgment
Tedder combo in this second fight of
cyrus heads toward left lane to avenge
his allied tier missing with sickle
strike his spirit flail clashes with
shocks Thunder strike and torrents combo
taking down several minions with hands
of the gods or cyrus carefully activates
the lord of the afterlife as another
spirit flail delivers the killing blow
in this final fight activating judgement
tether osiris dives directly into the
teamfight taking down Kali with basic
attacks he makes up for his earlier miss
a sickle strike on aura and a few basic
attacks rack up the kill count as a lord
of the afterlife judgement tether and
spirit flail deliver the Quadra kill
as the broken god of the afterlife
Osiris rises beyond the grave to hunt
down all who oppose him starting him off
with spirit flail provides Osiris with
an AoE while also giving him a movement
to speed rough next picking up sickle
strike and help Osiris further slow the
enemy while delivering additional damage
spirit flail combination with sickle
strike also further slow the target from
there
the priority shift to Lord of the
afterlife spirit flail judgement tether
sickle strike also introduced in this
patch is the two lane siege game-mode as
a new feature teams will earn points
towards spawning siege weapons as they
play
thanks for watching the smite God
revealed for Osiris broken god of the
afterlife